one of this country's wanted murder
suspects is in jail after an
international manhunt that lasted for
years 48 hours had the only news crew on
the scene when Peter Chadwick landed in
Los Angeles yesterday he disappeared in
2015 after being charged with killing
his wife 48 hours correspondent Tracy
Smith is following the case Tracy how
did investigators even find him good
morning tarika well we're expected to
hear more details later today when law
enforcement holds a news conference but
from what they've already told us they
got a tip that led them to Mexico where
Chadwick was living he was arrested
Sunday Sunday and he had numerous fake
IDs on him
Peter Chadwick returned to California
Monday in handcuffs and shackled at the
waist after more than four years on the
run authorities alleged the father of
three strangled his wife QC in their
Newport Beach home in October 2012
before placing her body in a dumpster in
San Diego County
Karen Thorpe was Q C's close friend we
showed her the images of Chadwick in
custody what's it like to see that I'm
angry I'm repulsed I want to make him
know the pain that everybody else
suffered originally Chadwick told
authorities a man named Juan whom he'd
hired to paint his house killed his wife
and forced him to drive her body to the
Mexican border where he called 9-1-1
they've gone into pickup truck
she's dead but police quickly realized
his story didn't add up 48 hours put a
spotlight on the international manhunt
back in May everyone we talked to and
described this one individual no one had
any idea who that was or could give us
any information related to this person
authorities said Chadwick also couldn't
explain the bite marks and scratches on
his body he pleaded not guilty after
being charged with murder in 2012 and
was released on a million dollars bail
two years later he vanished hoping for
new lead
the Newport Beach Police Department
produced a podcast revealing Chadwick
withdrew a large amount of cash from his
bank accounts and left behind
questionable reading material there are
books about changing your identity and
living off the grid clearly he's shocked
and surprised by what happened by being
caught in its time it's time for him to
pay at a hearing Wednesday prosecutors
are expected to ask the judge to deny
bail now Chadwicks attorney tells CBS
this morning he doesn't comment on
pending cases and he'll speak on behalf
of his client in court Jericka Thank You
JC way to follow that story